こんにちは
白衣をなくしたドクターススメだああ
ドクターあるなんではない皆さん日本のシャーペンの写真 not サーチ本的には何
ミリだと思います艦これアンたらみんなわかると思うんですよ
基本的に日本のシャーペンは0.5みんな地図のしかしたら世界共通なんだろう
自分を勝田日本だけなどともしれないと思って0
と国8 s & t さんの調べではですよアメリカ市場に関しては0.5ミリの
シャーペンはたったの25パーセント
0.7ミリの写真のシャベル70%のシェアを占めているらしいその他かどこ
つまりアメリカだと0.7ミリとシャーペイパー4が普通やっていいですよ
今年買った日本は0.5だけアメリカだと a 17
デューサー名なくをスタンダードってちょっと
びっくりしませんでしたなる今日はですねそんなアメリカでは主流になっている0.7
ミリのシャーペット障害でございますこちら虚空さんの鉛筆車
6種類でございますかなぁ意味がとても切る
jackrose カー種類とちゃんにーから私であれば
霊帝ならずベッド車ちょっとすごくないかなと思った人
そんなことがないんですアメリカだとみんなこういうのを使っているんですよ
ここから部の意見なんですけども#4つから人間は2種類に分かれると思います
一つは僕がコツですか僕はこちらですけどもうやりスピードを被ってる舐められて帰っ
て佐々木たいたい
スピード中ですね僕はもう強いスコープなんか勉強生物キッチンスピードなんでしょは
英単語を覚えるにはもう隠しかな
いいと思ってる僕はきゃいた方言ってしたスピードでもう一つはこんなにせずようさあ
ペット可
シンガー注い#を使っていこう
ゆっくりきれいな字を書きたい小さく書きたい美しく書きたい綺麗にどうとまとめ隊
キレイタイプ綺麗なノートに見せないという僕の流れ
2種類に分かれると思ってるんですけど今回紹介するとちょっとシャーペンはこっち側
の一人僕はお勧めした後過疎地域0じゃないし
どうぞもあれを見れればいいなと思っているようなタイプなので自分のスピードえっ
大歩くって舐められる楽してかける甲冑の特大しているので0.7の良い案って相談
しようと思いますひとつ目
とりあえずシャーシんだねそもそもぽれにくいですせずシーンが透明なので急い会でも
折れにくく
5時も濃いですってはっきり見えません中間わかると思うんだけどもええねぇ頃車
でも俺
いいねお力降りかかって保存筆圧良いなってこう力を込めて書くとするパキッと折れ
ちゃうとばかりです
レイズナーと側の赤化リスクなるとか見ています
キラッスタッフ偏差なぁから書けば濃度で着手するこのペン先がは前よりもことは
大きいわけですよあつーかざぐる
預かった部分大きいという理由はそれにこの遊び方ずその尽力が少なくなっているん
ですよねその圧力がプレッシャーこうねっ
拡散ってかがいいパンチにさあから避けるなぜええあのべき
漢字の練習とか猫たくさん2色とかしかなきゃいけない時とか大倉かけるいただきわけ
なんです
ちょっと自分でも何言ってる子さとりあえずささぁ開けて疲れにくいと思います
3つ目思ったより太ってないでしょまだ僕も使ってないんですけども情報によりますと
米ていただとあんまり0.5とさも変化がないんですよたので少なくとも0.5と
比べると安定感
て落ち着いにかけるテストでないだろ安心して書くということ探偵関して今回は今回
消費すると呼吸念仏チャージャーの安定カー求めたどうするに離れて自立のでさっそく
見ていこうと思いますこっちがキャンディーカラーの3種黒ピンク水色こっちが
クローズタイプどこの赤が一番好きです個人的にはこれ自由形車
沈んだけどフローズンからペンが三角形になっていますキャンディーカラーは6がっ型
になってます本当に鉛筆シャープなはで鉛筆の形をしています
相手でこちらの6種類になるでござるキャンディータイプはねなかなかプラスチック感
があって結構つるつるした感じなんですけど
フローズンタイプに関しては障
こちらさあはがせてすごい持ちやすいんですよこれいいね素晴らしいです
1滴でこちらの6種類なりまーでーな俺がねちょっと知ってほしいポイントはここなん
ですよシャーペイ知ってる人ならわかると思うんですけどもうなんと
で15分がついてなくて直にこのまま侵害入れますそれ個人に日驚いたことなんです
けど
ねえカチカチっているここにんですアップを取るとなんかなこの記事ゴムがついてるん
ですよ
それ生地感の取ってシャー芯を入れないけどそれだけ脂肪戻してキャップ怯える名んど
くさいな場所でが普通のシャーペンなんですかねしかし今回は呼吸予算の鉛筆喋る気
手法がついてなしキャップも付いていません好ましいよここにいれば
シャーペンのキャンプについてできしかも使えますかこれは絶対使いたくない人
その機能合ういたのはちょっとデカいと思います0.7ミリ専用のシャーシもしっかり
打ってます e 21 b
スポンはよう系でございますこれだけで写真の欲しいが降りていうスターはついてない
んですけども実はこれも降って来ないようにナックルで安全でございます
という流れか実は優れものの機能が付いているこちらの一発勝負でございます実際に
変えてみましょう
おおおいからそんなに超絶といったわけではないんですよねちゃう女が女ってならでし
たが0.5なんですけども交えて見た感じそんなに違いがないです
書きやすい北折ないのが好きの説法さあ佐々木拓ナチュラルはが全然描けます超綺麗
です愛的で次はこちらのですねと線画
入っているノートで小さい字書けるかどうかっていうのを確かめてみようと思います
迦陵頻伽とかも線を別にかけます0.7も0て風呂で正直あんまり変わりがない気が
するんですけど
この仙台は全然余裕で書けそうです了便が採石交換ねぇ切るコツ
電子報数一つも意味が
分かりませんプーラー
やっぱ車展示の人によってその使いやすい使い道があると思うんですけども僕にはもう
ジャストフィットしてますこれでさあ点で僕はレイターのプレイしました
おとうならドシッと構えて実家行成
何これふちゃんって
ん